we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal
that they are endowed by their creator
with certain unalienable rights
that among these are life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
without life there can be no liberty
without liberty
there is no happiness without equality
there is no opportunity
america has strived since its founding
to promote equality under the law
to correct injustices and to ensure
opportunity for all it is a work in
progress not always perfect
some look at american opportunity and
see only problems
they want equal outcome not equal
opportunities
they criticize without solutions demand
wealth without work
their ways are historical failures
evidenced by tyranny
and poverty a prevailing darkness in
every country it has been tried
the american dream inspired by american
opportunity is the engine of
entrepreneurship
oh it's beautiful mike the inspiration
to the greatest inventions
the highest achievements and
establishing the quality of life
second to none providing jobs creating
futures
fulfilling dreams in america
opportunity preserves individual freedom
it leads to exceptionalism it's a bright
shining light an example for all to sing
tonight
we explore together america
land of opportunity
[Music]
from washington d.c welcome to the 2020
republican national convention
celebrating america as the land of
[Music]
opportunity
[Music]
i'm going to invite you to join your
faith with mine
and let's pray in agreement lord we come
before you
to ask for your spirit of peace to come
over hurting communities in wisconsin
tonight
we pray for healing and comfort to jacob
blake and his family
we pray for your protection over those
who put their lives
in harm's way to bring safety and
security to our streets
we pray that the truth and justice will
be at the heart
of all decisions that are made by our
leaders
and that we as a people will seek
reconciliation with you
as we do the same with each other
thank you lord for your goodness over
our lives
for your blessing over our nation for
your guiding hand
over every person that calls the united
states of america
their home lord we thank you
for all that have gone before us and
have sowed seeds of sacrifice
for our freedom for our prosperity
and for our peace those that gave their
lives so that we could live
and achieve the american dream
your word declares in ii corinthians
where the spirit of the lord is there is
freedom
this country was founded by the people
for their god liberty freedom equality
it's what we want in our country
lord we invite you into our homes
into our lives give us revelation
that will overthrow any enemies that
stand against us
so that we will be victorious in this
next season
we need you let your kingdom come
let your will be done on earth as it is
in heaven
we surrender to your plans and purpose
for our lives
we ask bring heaven down to earth over
every person here and all those watching
today
as we move into this next chapter in our
journey to
greatness we ask for your presence to be
with us
lead us lord give us strategies from
heaven
i decree the words of isaiah 11 2 over
our president
vice president and all government
authorities from every state in our
nation
may the spirit of the lord rest on him
the spirit of wisdom and understanding
the spirit of counsel and might the
spirit of knowledge and the fear of the
lord
i release a blessing over every person
and every home
lord release health healing peace
strength and courage let us stand
together in unity
as we embrace another chapter on our
journey to greatness
i decree and declare america the best is
yet to come
and i ask all this in the name of jesus
amen
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
[Music]
i'm myron lizer the vice president of
the navajo nation
i give this address from the majestic
rock spires of shiprock
cebet's eye or rock with wings as known
by our dna people
it is here as well that many of our
ancestral leaders sought to govern
and lead a nation within a nation they
sought to lead their people into the
promises of a better way of life for
their children's children
it is also where they have not been as
successful as the rest of america
our first nations people the host people
of the land
we are still here our creator placed us
here
and knew for such a time as this we
would have an opportunity
for an appeal to heaven you see our
people have never been invited into the
american dream
we for years fought congressional
battles with past congressmen and
senators that
were part of a broken system that
ignored us that is
until president trump took office
president trump delivered the largest
financial funding package ever to indian
country
the eight billion dollars in cares act
funding to indian country was a great
start
in alleviating the devastating effects
that the covet-19 pandemic
has inflicted on our indian tribes the
navajo nation once led the nation in per
capita positive cases
because of the health disparities that
previous administrations failed to
improve
whenever we meet with president trump he
has always made it a priority to repair
the relationship
with our federal family recently
president trump
signed the first ever presidential
proclamation officially recognizing
missing and murdered american indians
and alaska natives
he established a task force called
operation lady justice to address the
problem
the president also provided 273 million
dollars
to improve public safety and support
victims of crime in the native american
community
as a result a cold case office was
recently opened on the gila river indian
community
the president has reactivated the white
house council on native american affairs
to promote economic development and
rural prosperity in the indian country
president trump also strengthened the
supreme court by nominating strong
conservative judges like neil gorsuch
who supports native american rights
thank you for the opportunity to be here
tonight
i'm excited to endorse president trump's
re-election
and mr president we look forward to
hosting you very soon
come visit our land we call dinette
thank you very much i had always had
this unshakable sense that i know that i
know
that life has to be more than what it
was i've been living
i caught my very first felony conviction
at 16 years old
and that type of behavior had led me
into more and more
arrests getting in trouble until he's 37
years old
i was arrested for a string of bank
robberies
and based off of my criminal history
there is a potential
that a federal judge can sentence me up
to
23 years in a maximum security united
states federal penitentiary
and in that moment i played a let's make
a deal with god
and i asked god to climb into the robe
of that judge
whether it's 10 years or 50 years i'm
going to
invest the rest of my life serving you
and i stood before that federal judge
judge mahan
took his glasses off leaned back and
said i don't know why i'm going to do
this
but he said i'm not going to give you
what you deserve
then he gave me a lesser sentence
and as i laid on that stainless steel
cell shock by my hands with my feet
i heard god utter into my spirit my son
i honored what you asked me to do
he said never forget the promise
that you made to me and ever since that
day
i got up off that floor and my life went
in a 180 degree turn
in the other direction when john got
that sentence i just shook my head i
said wow john you are destined for
for bigger things than in prison my name
is richard beasley
i was a fbi special agent for about 25
and a half years
it was something about his demeanor when
he walked into that room i had this
feeling like
everything is going to be okay then when
he got out he gave me a call and said
hey rich let's
let's have lunch so i met him at the
mcdonald's
and he's got a bible with him i've seen
that before where guys have used the
bible as a prop
it took me about 30 seconds to
understand that this was not a problem
with john he was a changed guy
from the man that i arrested you know
several years before
when i saw the way that he treated me
fairly
you know i saw the man behind the suit i
started thinking
man if that worked for me with this law
enforcement officer
how can i multiply that and get more law
enforcement officers involved
so that we can impact this on a larger
scale
president trump he had made a bunch of
promises let me just be transparent when
he first started talking about the
things he was going to do i'm sitting
there going wait a minute here
i mean is he serious because everything
he was saying that he wanted to do
wasn't stuff that needs to be done and
before he walked out
that meeting that day i promise i'll
make it out there
uh to you know come speak at one year
graduations i heard that they were
phenomenal
when he stood there in that graduation
and he
went out of his way to shake the hand
of every one of those 29 graduates
set them on a whole nother visit of life
because they had the office
of the president of the united states
the promises that he made was promises
that he can
two years ago i was honored to tell john
ponder's story of transformation
in the rose garden on the national day
of prayer
today i'm thrilled to welcome him back
to the white house
john's life is a beautiful testament to
the power
of redemption john grew up without his
father
as he tells it my mother was strong but
she wasn't able to keep us out of the
gangs and off of the streets
and they were violent streets at the age
of 38
he was arrested for bank robbery while
john was in prison he began reading the
bible
and listening to christian radio one day
he heard reverend billy graham on the
radio proclaimed
jesus wants to be lord of your life on
that day
john dedicated his life to christ he
spent the rest of his time in prison
studying the bible when he was released
he heard a knock at his door
it was the officer who put him in jail
fbi special agent richard beasley who
said
i want you to know that i've been
praying for you now richard and john
are best friends and we are grateful
that richard is here with us today
in the last 10 years since john was
released he has created one of the most
successful re-entry programs
hope for prisoners in las vegas i was
glad to speak there
earlier this year as john says
hope for prisoners is a movement that
began as a dream
in a tiny prison cell and is now making
a difference in the lives of thousands
truly bringing
hope that there is an opportunity and a
community that is waiting and willing to
offer them a second chance
john we honor your devotion to showing
returning citizens
that they are not forgotten we believe
that each person is
made by god for a purpose i will
continue to give all americans including
former inmates
the best chance to build a new life and
achieve their own
american dream and a great american
dream it is
now i'd like to ask john and richard to
say a few words
i can't tell you how grateful i am to
have the opportunity to speak here today
not so long ago my life was running from
the police
fearing the police and avoiding the
police not because of anything that the
police had done to me personally
but due to the animosity i had allowed
to grow inside of me
making me believe that they were my
enemy but today
praise god i am filled with hope a proud
american citizen
who has been given a second chance my
transformation began in a prison cell
where i found myself a three-time
convicted felon
facing yet another sentence i gave my
life to jesus and made him a promise
that i would spend the rest of my days
helping others
like me my first help and support came
from the unlikeliest of places
the fbi agent who arrested me richard
beasley
he is now a dear friend and has been a
source of encouragement
to me throughout my entire journey i am
grateful for the men and women of the
las vegas metropolitan police department
who volunteer their time to people will
return into our local community after
incarceration
these are the real life heroes who put
their lives on the line
every day armed with the promise that
they made to protect
and to serve have made a tremendous
impact in the lives of men and women
reintegrating back into our society my
hope for america
is that formerly incarcerated people
will be afforded the opportunity
to take advantage of the fact that we
live in a nation of second chances
my hope for america is that law
enforcement and people in the
communities across our country can come
together
and realize that as americans we have
more in common
than we have differences my hope for our
great nations to continue on this path
we are on
of being the most prosperous country in
the world
i'm so proud of john with his life's
turnaround and for all the lives that
he's helped to change
it may be hard to believe that as a
retired fbi agent
one of my best friends is a person i
arrested for bank robbery
when i met john 15 years ago he was
angry scared
frustrated and anxious about his future
on the drive to prison i stopped at a
convenience store
and bought john a coffee and a donut
after he was sentenced
john sent me a necktie and a note
thanking me for treating him like a
gentleman
five years later when he got out of
prison john called me and wanted to meet
for lunch
he was a different man he talked about
starting a re-entry program for men and
women coming out of prison
over time john earned the trust and
respect of the law enforcement community
many of whom volunteer in john's hope
for prisoners program
i'm grateful for president trump's
commitment to criminal justice reform
on february 20th of this year he was the
guest speaker at the hope for prisoners
graduation
he stayed much longer than scheduled to
hand out diplomas to the 29 men and
women
who graduated that day what a sight the
most important man in the free world
shaking hands and pledging his
administration's support to ex-offenders
their families were there the community
was there what a great second chance
i also appreciate president trump's
support for law enforcement
i always felt like i had strong support
as an fbi agent but there's nothing
worse than knowing you're being second
guessed when you're doing your job
in certain parts of our country right
now law enforcement doesn't feel like
they have the support from their local
leaders
they're being painted with a broad brush
unfairly with calls for defunding
but as president trump knows the
overwhelming percentage of law
enforcement officers are good
smart people are doing their jobs very
well
and they can change the world working
with people like john
thank you so now i'd like to invite
john's wife jamie to join us
as i grant john i'm not sure you know
this
a full pardon
so i don't know if you know that jamie
come on over here
it's just an honor and uh you have done
incredible work thank you sir
and all of las vegas and all of nevada
and all of every place in this country
is very proud of you the job you've done
bringing people back and you're right i
was supposed to be there for five
minutes i stayed for an hour
because it was so interesting to me
congratulations to both
thank you sir richard thank you very
much for the job you do
thank you fantastic thank you
okay i think i'll give it to jaime
good evening i'm senator rand paul from
kentucky
donald trump and i met many years ago
before he was running for anything
when i first met him i recall being
struck by how down to earth he was
he seemed like just a normal guy okay a
normal guy with his own
plane and helicopter but who's counting
i was planning a medical mission trip to
guatemala to perform charity eye
surgeries
and we needed money to fund the trip
donald trump
offered to help and immediately came
through for us not only did he support
my medical mission to guatemala
but he also contributed to another
mission trip to haiti a year later
we performed hundreds of cataract
surgeries in both countries
nothing is more amazing than removing
the bandages from a person's eyes
and watching them as they see their
loved ones again
donald trump helped me make that happen
a few years later we were opponents both
running for president
we all know how that turned out but i'm
proud of the job donald trump has done
as president
i don't always agree with him but our
occasional policy differences are far
outweighed by our significant agreements
but more important than simple agreement
is accomplishment
president trump gets things done when
some in congress wanted a so-called
revenue neutral tax plan donald trump
and i
worked together to make sure that it was
a true
tax cut i brought president trump an
idea for better
less expensive health insurance called
association health plans
donald trump overturned years of red
tape and bureaucrats
and he made it happen while others
talked about criminal justice reform
president trump actually signed the
first step
act the first real reform in a
generation
and one that sought to undo the harm
that others
like joe biden have done for those of us
who lament
the biden crime bill that locked up a
generation of young black men
remember that biden bragged about a bill
that still wreaks havoc among people of
color
i'm supporting president trump because
he believes as i do
that a strong america cannot fight
endless wars
we must not continue to leave our blood
and treasure in middle east quagmires
i flew with him to dover air force base
to honor two soldiers whose remains were
coming home from afghanistan
i'll never forget that evening i can
tell you the president not only felt the
pain of these families
but the president is committed to ending
this war
president trump is the first president
in a generation to seek to end
war rather than start one he intends to
end the war in afghanistan he is
bringing
our men and women home madison once
wrote
no nation can preserve its freedom in
the midst of continuous warfare
i'm proud to finally see a president who
agrees with that
compare president trump with a
disastrous record of joe biden
who has consistently called for more war
joe biden voted for the iraq war
which president trump has long called
the worst
geopolitical mistake of our generation
i fear biden will choose war again he
supported the war in serbia
syria libya joe biden will continue to
spill
our blood and treasure president trump
will bring our heroes home if you hate
war like i hate war
if you want us to quit sending 50
billion dollars
every year to afghanistan to build their
roads and bridges
instead of building them here at home
you need to support president trump
for another term so to our soldiers and
their families
join me in supporting president trump
to those of you who want lower taxes and
better
less expensive health care join me in
supporting president trump
to those of you who want to stand up and
fight the socialists
poisoning our schools and burning our
cities
join me in supporting president trump
let's rebuild america together
[Music]
what i would call your everyday man the
forgotten
uh man or woman the people that wake up
every morning
go to work do their job come home to
their kids and families and are faithful
and
the people that have built america
there are people in our country that
have been forgotten
that are hard workers we do not hold
signs
we are not on street corners we are
waking up
at the crack of dawn working and earning
our living
but every single day men and women form
across this country
are affecting people in positive ways
real people that work hard every day
and they just want to earn a good living
and enjoy life
and he really knows them understands
them
it's clear he has been on the job site
interacting with people from all
backgrounds
i've never had someone care so much
about
making sure people have some job
security
the president's job is to protect us
keep us safe
and help make our life better in the
opportunity to pursue the american dream
that's what donald trump is doing
as a cattle rancher and a farmer i do
feel that
we are not forgotten with this
administration we have hope
for preserving our industry
my hope is that we lift the regulations
that
have stripped away the working-class
americans ability to do what they
innately know how to do best
i feel like trump is definitely pushing
more
for the steel mills the fishermen
just us making our own products and
bringing everything in
he's pushing so hard and i see it truly
coming
alive i do feel that
president trump has the interests of
all those americans tied together i
really do
[Music]
good evening my name is jason joyce and
i'm an eighth generation lobster
fisherman from swans island maine
i make my living from lobster fishing
oyster farming and providing eco tours
in the beautiful waters near acadia
national park where i have over 200
years of family history
i have to confess i didn't support trump
in 2016.
skeptical that he shared my conservative
views i expected him to flip-flop on his
campaign promises
but he has followed through in his
promises including last week when he
brokered a deal to end
european union tariffs of eight percent
on main live lobsters
and up to 20 percent on maine lobster
products which is great news for maine's
lobster men and women
i live in an island with 370 residents
and lobstering is how we provide for our
families
maine's lobstermen are true
environmentalists we practice
conservation every day
if we didn't we'd be putting ourselves
out of business
four years ago the obama biden
administration used the antiquities act
to order thousands of square miles of
ocean off limits to commercial fishermen
they did it to cater to environmental
activists although maine's lobstermen
don't fish there
obama's executive order offended us
greatly it circumvented
the fisheries council's input president
trump reversed that decision
reinstating the rules that allow
stakeholder input
and he supports a process that seeks and
respects fisherman's views
as long as trump is president fishing
families like mine will have a voice
but if biden wins he'll be controlled by
the environmental extremists who want to
circumvent long-standing rules
and impose radical changes that hurt our
coastal communities i strongly support
president trump's re-election
when he sees something isn't right he's
fearless in fixing it
he listens to working people he
nominates judges who respect the
constitution and the right to life
he keeps his word like eliminating the
european tariffs
and moving the u.s embassy from tel aviv
to jerusalem
i hope you will join me this time in
voting for president trump
stand up for your country thank you
[Music]
good evening my name is chris peterson
my husband gary our family and i milk a
thousand cows on a dairy farm in
grantsburg wisconsin
a small middle american town truth be
told
until i married my cute farmer from
grantsburg a long time ago
i was a city slicker from minneapolis
which is about 70 miles south of us
donald trump became president in the
middle of the great depression for dairy
farmers
in wisconsin in 2016 prices were
horrible
and long time generational farms across
the nation were going out of business
in 2017 our 120 year old barn
which served as our milking center
caught fire and burned to the ground
our cows were spared but because they
needed to be milked three times a day
farmers friends and complete strangers
from all over northern wisconsin
helped haul them to other farms where
they stayed until we could rebuild
by the end of 2018 we had a new
state-of-the-art
robotic milking facility that allows our
cows to milk themselves three times a
day
at about the same time president trump's
economic boon began helping
dairy farmers across the nation as a
businessman
president trump understands that farming
is a complicated
capital intensive and risky business
more than any president in my lifetime
he has acknowledged the importance of
farmers and agriculture
that support and focus on negotiating
new trade deals
gave us the confidence to rebuild our
barn and dairy operation
business was booming again and business
boomed right until the covid19 shut down
in march
many people probably don't realize that
our country is one of the few in the
world
that produces nearly all of its own food
fewer still understand how close our
food production
and distribution system came to
collapsing this past spring
but president trump understood and again
took steps to provide the supports we
needed
president trump took the necessary
action knowing that agriculture is our
backbone and strength
critical to our national security our
entire economy
and dairy farming are once again roaring
back
one person deserves the credit and our
vote
president donald j trump
[Music]
what was happening prior to president
trump you had businesses that were over
regulated
not a friendly environment at all to
start a company
my family stopped ranching about seven
years ago the regulations became so
overbearing
that the ranch was slowly sold off
i lost businesses because of this
regulation
the factories in our town closed the
businesses in our towns have shut
it got to the point finally that middle
america needed help
president trump came in and was able to
shed light on an area that had been so
long left behind
tax cuts and jobs act was huge
especially for a community like ours
that has a lot of small businesses
manufacturing deregulation fair trade
real life policy changes that affected
real americans
an amazing opportunity to get ahead to
have our businesses to have our children
educated
of school choice that is something
that's huge for parents right now
especially black moms
whose kids are trapped in failing school
districts before kobe hit
black unemployment rate was at the
lowest ever i've seen
the numbers of employees go up and
they're earning
a lot more for their family than what
they had previously
what this administration has done
simplifying the government
it's really cut the handcuffs off of
america again and allowed us to grow and
move forward in a way that i have never
seen in my lifetime
when you pull regulation and allow small
companies to go out there and be able to
play in the game
that is the american dream people feel
that they can
support and have a family and it can
build and make
us stronger as americans what could be
taken away
if he doesn't win again joe biden said
the first thing he's going to do
is increase taxes on everyone over
regulating
and making it where a small business can
grow that's taking away the american
dream
i think with the upcoming election
people just need to think about
what is better for them and their family
the president's job is to be the ceo of
our country
and he's doing his job he has
improved jobs he's improved health he's
improved
wages he's cut taxes
i could go on for an hour and a half the
plan was working everybody had a job
making money spending money
my kids are gonna look up to me and say
you are the best mom
for working raising us it's just
tremendous what i could do i guess
this is somebody who loves his country
he's truly fighting for the american
people
[Music]
hello folks you know me from tv and
radio i'm
larry kudlow years ago i worked for
ronald reagan
more recently i helped the team craft
donald trump's economic plan during the
campaign
it was a roaring success inheriting a
stagnant economy on the front end of
recession
the program of tax cuts historic
rollback of onerous regulations that
crippled small business
unleashing energy to become the world's
number one producer
and free fair and reciprocal trade deals
to bolster manufacturing
agriculture technology and other sectors
the economy was rebuilt in three years
unemployment fell to the lowest rate of
3.5 percent
blue colors african-americans hispanics
women
all groups benefited enormously everyone
was better off
a rising tide lifted all boats
then came a once in 100 year pandemic
it was awful health and economic impacts
were tragic hardship
and heartbreak were everywhere but
presidential leadership came swiftly and
effectively with an extraordinary rescue
for health and safety
to successfully fight the covet virus a
great bipartisan rescue
also saved the economy right now our
economic health is coming back
with emergency spending and tax cuts
americans are going
back to work there's a housing boom
there's an auto boom
a manufacturing boom a consumer spending
boom
stocks are in record territory a
v-shaped recovery
is pointing to better than 20 percent
growth in the second half of this year
now looking ahead more tax cuts and
regulatory rollback will be in store
payroll tax cuts for higher wages income
tax cuts for the middle class
capital gains tax cuts for investment
productivity
and jobs much more regulatory relief for
small businesses
in economic terms folks this is no
time for a 4 trillion dollar tax hike
coming out of the deep pandemic who in
their right mind
would pick the pockets of taxpayers and
drain money from their wallets and
purses look our economic choice is very
clear
do you want economic health prosperity
opportunity and optimism or do you want
to turn back
to the dark days of stagnation recession
and pessimism i believe there can't be
better economic policies than we've had
in
recent years so i say stay
with them thank you
i'm john peterson owner of a second
generation
metal fabrication business called shooty
metals
we've been stamping our products and
services made in the usa
since 1957. my brother and i purchased
the business
from my uncles almost 38 years ago what
was a 12-person shop
has now grown into a company employing
165 people today
like most companies that are successful
over the long run
we had to reinvent ourselves as the
market changed
six years ago we invested heavily in our
business
just as the greatest recession appeared
barack obama
and joe biden two career politicians
who knew nothing about business couldn't
get the government out of our way
and it put our business in a tailspin
sadly we were forced to make decisions
which included cutting staff a torturous
experience
when our employers are like family
the obama biden era banking regulations
left us
no choice it tied our lenders hands
and it drived us of the lifeblood of our
business
capital we scratched
and we clawed for two years and then
everything
changed donald trump was elected
president
and he knew what it was like to build a
company and create jobs
one of the first things he did was to
cut red tape
and put an end to draconian type banking
regulations
he also cut taxes on small businesses
allowing us to be more competitive both
domestically and
internationally in fact we increased
revenues by 25
for two years in a row by getting rid of
the job killing nafta
and negotiating the u.s mexican canada
trade agreement
president trump ensured a more
competitive playing field
for american companies even with all the
challenges presented by the coronavirus
president trump is rebuilding and our
economy
is roaring back again
but when i hear that joe biden is ready
to raise
taxes crush us with regulations
and weaken our international trade
position
i shudder we simply cannot endure
a biden induced recession some will
struggle
some will not survive and working men
and women of america
will get crushed yet again
this is not time to hand our government
over to
a washed up career politician
who will be nothing but a puppet of the
radical left democrats
as a lifelong resident of wisconsin i'm
a fan of the badger football team
many may not realize that the wisconsin
badgers and the president share three
common qualities
they are smart they're tough and they're
dependable
as a businessman i can tell you that
those qualities
we need in our country's leader and
that's why we need to re-elect donald j
trump thank you and god bless america
[Music]
good evening i'm [ __ ] graham lynch
and i'm honored to speak to you tonight
about something that is so
important to all of us our faith
as americans we know the first line of
the first amendment
protects our freedom of religion but
what we often forget the actual words
are free exercise of religion
that means living out our faith in our
daily lives
in our schools and our jobs and yes
even in the public square our founders
did not envision a quiet
hidden faith they fought to ensure that
the voices of faith
were always welcomed not silenced
not bullied but during the obama biden
administration
these freedoms were under attack
democrats tried to make faith
organizations pay for abortion inducing
drugs
democrats tried to force adoption
agencies
to violate their deeply held beliefs
democrats pressured schools to allow
boys
to compete in girls sports and use girls
locker rooms
those are the facts but then
we the people elected donald trump
people of faith suddenly had a fierce
advocate in the white house
he appointed judges who respect the
first amendment
he supported religious beliefs in court
he ensured religious ministries would
not be forced to violate
their beliefs he withdrew the policies
that placed our little girls at risk
and on the world stage president trump
became the first president
to talk about the importance of
religious freedom at the united
nations giving hope to people
faith around the world in america we
have not yet experienced physical
persecution
even though the left has tried to
silence us
even during the pandemic we saw how
quickly life can change
some democratic leaders tried to ban
church services
while marijuana shops and abortion
clinics were declared essential
but you know what truly is essential our
right to worship freely
and live our faith in every aspect of
life
the biden harris vision for america
leaves no room
for people of faith whether you're a
baker or florist or a football coach
they will force the choice between being
obedient to god
or to caesar because the radical left's
god
is government power so in the words of
my grandfather
billy graham let us stand for political
freedom
moral freedom religious freedom and the
rights of all americans
and let's never give in to those who
would attempt to take it from us
tonight i'm proudly standing in that
public square
and i hope and pray you will join me
in voting to re-elect president trump
i am bob lozalovich mayor of eblith a
small town in the iron range of
minnesota
my father and grandfather earned their
livings mining the raw materials that
made the steel
that built america this election is a
make or break for workers who are
carrying on the legacy of men like them
since the iron range economy is
vulnerable to economic trends
and to foreign trade we have always
needed a strong voice in washington
we looked to democrats to fill that void
for many years because
we actually thought they cared about our
welfare
not anymore the radical environmental
movement has dragged the democratic
party so far
to the left they can no longer claim to
be advocates
of the working man this is hard for me
to say because i
am a lifelong democrat but for far
too long members of both parties allowed
our country to be ripped off by our
trading partners
especially china who dumped steel into
our markets
and slap tariffs on our products and
what did so-called leaders like joe
biden do
nothing the human cost has been
devastating
we lost thousands of jobs we lost a
generation of young people
who had to leave the iron range to find
a livelihood
and worst of all we lost hope then
something unexpected happened
a straight-talking new yorker burst onto
the scene promising to stand up to china
and the rest of the world on behalf of
the american worker
four years later the iron range is
roaring back to life
and we have one man to thank president
donald trump
he made good on his promises by cutting
our taxes
rolling back senseless regulations and
delivering trade deals that put
america's interests first
but the fight is not over joe biden has
allowed radicals like aoc
to craft his environmental policies
their so-called green new deal
is a job-killing disgrace dreamt up by
people who don't live
in the real world but biden is too weak
too scared
and too sleepy to stand up to the
radical left
he has been doing nothing in washington
for 47 years
why would year 48 be any different
president trump won't back down to
anybody
he delivered the best economy in our
history and he will do it again
for all of us the iron ranges economic
future and survival is at stake
and so is america's we know we can count
on president trump to fight for us
and win let's make sure he wins on
november 3rd
god bless america
[Music]
my name is abby johnson and i spent
eight years
working for planned parenthood but today
i am a pro-life activist
when i was in college planned parenthood
approached me at a volunteer fair
they talked about helping women in
crisis and their commitment to keep
abortion
safe legal and rare i was convinced to
volunteer and later offered a full-time
job as a medical assistant before my
promotion to director of the clinic
i truly believed i was helping women
but things drastically changed in 2009
in april i was awarded planned
parenthood's employee of the year award
and invited to their annual gala where
they present the margaret
sanger award named for their founder
and margaret sanger was a racist who
believed in eugenics
her goal when founding planned
parenthood was to eradicate
the minority population today almost
80 percent of planned parenthood
abortion facilities are strategically
located in minority neighborhoods
and every year planned parenthood
celebrates
its racist roots by presenting the
margaret
sanger award later in august
my supervisor assigned me a new quota to
meet
an abortion quota i was expected to sell
double the abortions performed the
previous year
when i pushed back underscoring planned
parenthood's public public-facing goal
of decreasing abortions i was
reprimanded and told
abortion is how we make our money
but the tipping point came a month later
when a physician
asked me to assist with an ultrasound
guided
abortion nothing prepared me
for what i saw on the screen an
unborn baby fighting back desperate
to move away from the suction and
i'll never forget what the doctor said
next
beam me up scotty the last thing
i saw was a spine twirling around
in the mother's womb before succumbing
to the force
of the suction on october 6
i left the clinic looking back only to
remember
why i now advocate so passionately for
life
i founded and currently run and then
there were none
a non-profit organization that's helped
nearly 600
abortion workers transition out of the
industry
for most people who consider themselves
pro-life abortion
is abstract they can't even conceive of
the barbarity
they don't know about the products of
conception room and abortion clinics
where infant corpses are pieced back
together
to ensure nothing remains in the
mother's wombs
or that we joked and called it the
pieces of children room
you see for me abortion is real
i know what it sounds like i know what
abortion
smells like did you know abortion
even had a smell i've been the
perpetrator to these babies
to these women and i now support
president trump because he has done more
for the unborn than
any other president during his first
month in office
he banned federal funds for global
health groups that promote abortion
that same year he overturned an obama
biden rule
that allowed government subsidy of
abortion he appointed
a record number of pro-life judges
including two supreme court justices
and importantly he announced a new rule
protecting the rights of health care
workers objecting to abortion many
of whom i work with every day
life is a core tenant of who we are as
americans
and this election is a choice between
two
radical anti-life activist and the most
pro-life president we have ever had
that's something that should compel you
to action
go door-to-door make calls talk to your
neighbors and friends
and vote on november 3rd take
action that reelects our president and
do it
with our very most vulnerable americans
in mind the ones who haven't been born
yet
[Music]
it began as a class trip to join
thousands for the annual march for life
these catholic young men traveled from
kentucky to stand up for what they
believed in
but what happened was something very
different
crackers would make america great you
little dirty
crackers your day coming young clansmen
look at how make america great again
social media the news and even
celebrities
launched a campaign of persecution that
was completely false
against a boy in a make america great
again hat
the maga hat carries a certain
connotation that provokes
a conditioned reaction i blame that
[ __ ] kid
what a little girl everyone that sees
that smug look wants to punch that kid
nicholas sandman received death threats
and his school was forced to close
tonight
nicholas tells his story
good evening everyone my name is nick
sandman
and i'm the teenager who was defamed by
the media after an encounter with a
group of protesters on the steps of the
lincoln memorial last year
before i begin i'd like to thank
president trump for the opportunity to
share some of my story
and why it matters so much to this
november's election
in 2019 i attended the march for life in
washington dc
where i demonstrated in defense of the
unborn
later that day i bought a make america
great again hat
because our president donald trump has
distinguished himself as one of the most
pro-life presidents
in the history of our country and i
wanted to express
my support for him too looking back now
how could i possibly imagine that the
simple act
of putting on that red hat would unleash
hate from the left
and make myself the target of network
and cable news networks
nationwide being from kentucky
the birthplace of abraham lincoln my
classmates and i visited the lincoln
memorial
i found myself face to face with nathan
phillips
and other professional protesters
looking to turn me
into the latest poster child showing why
trump is bad
well the media portrayed me as an
aggressor with a relentless
smirk on my face in reality the video
confirms i was standing with my hands
behind my back
and an awkward smile on my face that hid
two thoughts
one don't do anything that might further
agitate the man banging a drum
in my face and two i was trying to
follow a family friend's advice
never to do anything to embarrass your
family
your school or your community
before i knew what was happening it was
over
one of mr phillips fellow agitators yet
up
we got him it's all right here on video
and we won grandpa what i thought was a
strange
encounter quickly developed into a major
news story
complete with video footage my life
changed forever in that one moment
the full war machine of the mainstream
media revved up into attack mode
they did so without researching the full
video of the incident
without ever investigating mr phillips
motives
or without ever asking me for my side of
the story
and do you know why because the truth
was not important advancing their
anti-christian
anti-conservative anti-donald trump
narrative was all that mattered
and if advancing their narrative ruin
the reputation and future of the
teenager from covington kentucky
well so be it that would teach him not
to wear a mega hat
i learned what was happening to me had a
name
it was called being canceled as an
annulled
as in revoked as in made void
cancelled is what's happening to people
around this country who refuse to be
silenced by the far left
many are being fired humiliated or even
threatened
and often the media is a willing
participant
but i would not be canceled i fought
back hard to expose the media for what
they did to me
and i won a personal victory while much
more must be done
i look forward to the day that the media
returns to providing balanced
responsible and accountable news
coverage i know president trump hopes
for that too
and i know you'll agree with me when we
say that no one in this country
has been a victim of unfair media
coverage more than president donald
trump
in november i believe this country must
unite
around a president who calls the media
out
and refuses to allow them to create a
narrative
instead of reporting the facts i believe
we must join a president who will
challenge the media to return to
objective journalism
and together i believe we must all
embrace our first amendment rights
and not hide in fear of the media or
from the tech companies
or from the outrage mob either this is
worth fighting for
this is worth voting for and this is
what donald
trump stands for thank you all for
listening to me tonight
and one more thing let's make america
[Music]
great
[Music]
i'm pam bondi our party's theme tonight
is america the land of opportunity
and listening to the stories of
discoveries and deliverance
you can't help but be proud to call this
country
home but for joe biden it's been the
land of opportunism
not opportunity as a career prosecutor
and former attorney general of florida i
fought corruption
and i know what it looks like whether
it's done by people wearing pinstripe
suits
or orange jumpsuits as
at the democrats convention we were told
to look at joe biden as the model of
integrity
but when you look at his 47-year career
in politics
the people who benefited are his family
members
not the american people let's take a
closer look
we all know about joe's son hunter biden
a corrupt ukrainian oligarch
put hunter on the board of his gas
company even though he had no experience
in ukraine
or in the energy sector none yet he was
paid
millions to do nothing he only had
one qualification that mattered he was
the son of the man in charge of
distributing usaid
to ukraine and recently reported
information revealed that a few months
after hunter biden joined that corrupt
company's board
the obama biden state department began
doing
business with them even when it remained
under investigation for corruption
and it gets worse that very same company
was being investigated by a ukrainian
prosecutor
joe biden the vice president of the
united states
threatened to withhold aid to ukraine
unless that same prosecutor was fired
and then he was fired
hunter only resigned from that board
just before his dad announced
his campaign for president
now let's talk about china fact
joe biden flew to china on air force two
with hunter along for the ride
they said he was just there as a family
member but we know
that's untrue in beijing hunter didn't
just go sightseeing
he had meetings with his chinese bank
partners
hunter even arranged for his dad to meet
with one of the partners
ten days later those chinese communist
bankers
approved millions to go to hunter's firm
and those bankers work for the chinese
communist
party which oppresses their people
cheated american workers for decades
and covered up a deadly virus
to this day hunter controls a 10
stake in that firm and joe biden's done
more than
look the other way on china he said the
chinese aren't our competition
come on man they're not bad folks
come on joe talk to the folks in middle
america
who lost countless jobs to china while
your son was getting rich with them
but there's more fact there have been
numerous
press reports that have shown other
close biden family members
benefited from joe's 47 year political
career
joe biden was point person on iraq
the president of a construction firm met
with biden's team in the white house and
then
who did they hire to build thousands of
houses in iraq
joe biden's close family member who you
guessed it
had no experience in the industry and no
experience in iraq
a company official bragged that it helps
to have a family member the vice
president as partner
the family member put it more bluntly by
saying
there's a line of 747s
filled with cash ready to invest
now let's follow the money down south
again as reported in the press
yet another close family member of joe's
set his sights on costa rica and jamaica
where millions of dollars flowed from
the obama biden administration
in taxpayer-backed loans to projects
linked to
yes that same family member these
aren't isolated incidents it is a
deliberate
pattern of conduct and that's just what
he did
as vice president imagine what he'd do
as president how many american families
would be allowed to get away with this
why should there be one standard for the
elite political class
and another set of rules for the rest of
us
when millions of americans voted for
donald trump
they knew he'd be different and he is
he's a tough no-nonsense outsider
who can't be bought or intimidated he
won't even take a paycheck
from the american people he donates his
paycheck to charities
across this country democrats have been
lecturing america about integrity for
four years
while their nominee has been writing the
textbook
on abuse of power for 40 years if they
want to make this election a choice
between who's saving america
and who's swindling america bring it on
joe says he'll build back better yeah
build the biden's back better our
president
is in this to build a safer better
and stronger america and he will finish
what he started to keep this a real
land of opportunity for everyone
if you want to check your voting status
secure your ballot
or register to vote text vote
to 88022
remember the best is yet to come
[Music]
women have played a very very big role
uh the level of
genius is unbelievable frankly you're
what you've got 70 80 years on this
earth
what are you going to do with it are you
going to make that difference are you
going to
say i was there for the big battles
in our country to save america it's what
i feel
very much called to do ever since i was
a very young girl
in 2016 donald trump made his historic
run for the office of united states
president
knowing the monumental task he would be
undertaking he rested all of his hopes
for winning
on one woman because of that trust he
became the 45th president of the united
states
and kellyanne conway became the first
woman in u.s history
to manage a winning presidential
campaign this president
has been a champion for women
mostly because he speaks to them
as if they can handle and tackle all
issues i don't want a job
because of my gender i want the job
because i'm the best person for that
position
that's it and he respects that and he
appreciates
hard work you can't ask for anything
better especially in a boss
president trump continues to place
strong women into significant positions
throughout his administration
and campaign far more than any other
president in u.s history
that he has had and does have more women
on his top team
than any president before but it
actually goes down to his deputy
assistance to his special assistants to
our awesome teams throughout the west
wing and when he called me and said
i want you to represent my entire
campaign i became the first
black woman to represent a republican
presidential campaign
winning presidential campaign in united
states history
throughout his career trump has always
touted family first as a core value
he shows this especially with his
choices of press secretaries
choosing sarah sanders the first mother
to become a press secretary
stephanie grisham the first single
mother to serve as press secretary
and kaylee mcinenneny who transitioned
into the job
while also transitioning into the job of
mom i have four children kellyanne
conway has four children ivanka has
i think between all the senior staff
women we might have 75 kids i'm not sure
we've lost count but the importance of
the work is never lost on any of us
and truly it is those children that we
are fighting for and for their future
with these capable women placed in
positions of powerful influence and
authority
president trump has proven that when the
stakes are highest
he is proud to entrust many of our
nation's most crucial jobs
to women the number of dedicated
amazing brilliant relentless women that
are dedicated to the country and to the
president
and to preserving the american dream is
one of the greatest if not the greatest
things i'll ever be
a part of
only the president would say let's take
that stay-home mom and have her run the
party
what a smart guy
[Music]
good evening i'm tiffany trump since
speaking at the republican convention
four years ago so much has changed for
the world
for our country and for my family like
so many students across the world
i graduated from law school during the
pandemic
our generation is unified in the facing
the future in uncertain times and many
of us
are considering what kind of country we
want to live in
as a recent graduate i can relate to so
many of you
who might be looking for a job my father
built a thriving economy once
and believe me he will do it again
this election i urge each and every one
of you
to transcend political boundaries this
is a fight for freedom versus oppression
for opportunity versus stagnation a
fight to keep america
true to america i urge you to make
judgment
based on results and not rhetoric if you
believe
in criminal justice reform there is only
one president
that passed the first stepped act giving
people
a second chance a chance at a life once
again
and if you believe in expanding quality
and affordable health care only
president trump
my father signed the right to try into
law
the favored nations clause and other
actions to lower drug prices
and keep americans from getting ripped
off
people must recognize that our thoughts
our opinions and even the choice of who
we are
voting for may and are being manipulated
and visibly coerced by the media and
tech giants
if you tune into the media you get one
biased opinion or another
and what you share if it does not fit
into the narrative that they
seek to promote then it is either
ignored or deemed a lie
regardless of the truth this
manipulation of what
information we receive impedes our
freedoms
rather than allowing americans the right
to form our
own beliefs this misinformation system
keeps people mentally enslaved to the
ideas
they deem correct this has fostered
unnecessary fear
and divisiveness amongst us why
are so many in media and technology
and even in our own government so
invested in promoting
a biased and fabricated view
ask yourselves why are we prevented from
seeing certain information
why is one viewpoint promoted while
others are hidden
the answer is control because division
and controversy breed profit
but what are the consequences when only
one side of the story gets out
or when only one viewpoint is acceptable
for our education system it means
sacrificing
civil debate by creating an atmosphere
where students
with contrary opinions are too afraid to
speak
many students find themselves
suppressing their beliefs to fit into
what
the acceptable group think is in short
our nation suffers by inhibiting our
diversity of thought
and ideas working together
outside of our political comfort zones
will accomplish
so much more some cynical politicians
do not seem to believe in the miracle of
america
well i do as maximal alvarez said so
eloquently last night
if freedom is lost in this country there
is nowhere
else to go having hope
is not weakness and believing in
miracles
is a gift from god so tonight
i want to tell you the uncensored truth
of what we believe in
we believe in equality of opportunity
we believe in freedom of thought and
expression
think what you want seek out the truth
learn from those with different opinions
and then freely
make your voice heard to the world we
believe in school choice because a child
zip code in america
should not determine their future we
believe in freedom of religion for
all faiths and we believe
in the american spirit a country founded
on ideas
not identity a country where our
differences are embraced
and the only country where the word
dream has been attached to it
because in america your life
is yours to chart so if you're hearing
these things
and thinking to yourself that is the
kind of country that i want to live in
well whether you realize it or not you
are a trump supporter
i encourage you to see beyond the facade
that so many other politicians employ
they mask themselves in disguises of
decency
as they try to pressure us to mask our
own identities and beliefs
my father is the only person to
challenge the establishment
the entrenched bureaucracy big pharma
and media monopolies
to ensure that americans constitutional
freedoms are upheld
and that justice and truth prevail my
father
does not run away from challenges even
in the face of outright hatred
because fighting for america is
something he will sacrifice
anything for he dreams big dreams for
our country
and he is relentless at achieving them
you see
make america great again is not a slogan
for my father it is what drives him to
keep his promise of doing what is right
for american citizens the energy of
change
and opportunity is with us god has
blessed us with unstoppable spirit
his spirit the american spirit my dad
has proven to be driven by that spirit
he has demonstrated his faith and his
uncompromising heart
and actions my father has made me
believe that america
can truly be great again
if you care about living your life
without restraints
about rebelling against those who would
suppress your voice
and building your american dream then
the choice in this election is clear
a vote for my father donald j trump
is a vote to uphold our american ideals
be true to yourself and stay true to the
dream of america
thank you and god bless you all
i'm kim reynolds governor of the great
state of iowa
i love this state and i'm so proud to
serve its people
iowa truly is a land of opportunity
it's the birthplace of the computer it's
a landmark of the financial services
industry
and as so many of you already know it's
filled with farmland that feeds and
fuels
the world it's also home to people who
care for one another
who work hard who love this country
and are truly grateful for the freedoms
it provides
as i like to say iowa is one big small
town
neighbor helping neighbor is in our dna
from the sick farmer who can't harvest
his crops
to the single mom who loses her job and
is struggling to get back on her feet
the town the community helps them get
through it
but what happens when a storm rips
through almost the entire state
when it's not one farmer who lost his
crop
but hundreds when it's not one neighbor
who is without food
but thousands that happened just two
weeks ago
a storm called a derecho with hurricane
force winds
of up to 140 miles per hour wiped out
millions of acres of crops left
thousands without power
it destroyed homes wrecked lives and
left
devastation in its wake it was the worst
storm in our state's history
and iowans did what you expect iowans to
do
they helped each other they took care of
each other and they still are
but someone else had our back our
president
when the winds had finished raging and
the cleanup had
only begun he showed up now you might
not know that because the national media
didn't report it
but the trump administration was here in
full force
the day after the storm the president
called to assure me
that we had the full backing of the
federal government
and later that week vice president pence
came to iowa to again
assure us that the president and his
administration
were behind us with the help of the
trump administration we
quickly received a major disaster
declaration
that will help iowans get back on their
feet
the president he cut through the
bureaucracy to do what needed to be done
and to do it quickly but that's not the
first time
president trump showed iowans that we
can rely on him
in 2019 when 100-year floods
breached nearly every levee and
devastated communities large and small
along the missouri river in iowa
nebraska and missouri
the president approved our request for
aid
in record time in just two days well
this year
he did it in less than 24 hours
so whether it's providing needed relief
to farmers
who were the target of china's unfair
trade practices
hammering out new free and fair trade
deals
or fighting for workers in small
businesses who were hit hard
by covid19 we have a president and a
vice president
who get things done and because of
president trump
and his leadership our country is able
to bounce
back from setbacks and see opportunity
grow and thrive this is an
administration of action
and outcomes they are delivering every
day on their promise to make
america great again and that's exactly
why we need to reelect president
donald j trump in november thank you and
may
god bless the united states of america
america
the land of opportunity
[Music]
a country where your own resolution to
succeed
is more important than any other
[Music]
abraham lincoln's words from 165 years
ago
still resonate today because of who we
are
and because of what we are a country
where a boy
born into poverty in a log cabin raised
right here on the frontier of indiana
could educate himself become a lawyer
become a president of the united states
who would preserve the union
abolish slavery and save the nation
as a fellow hoosier visiting lincoln's
boyhood home
has always been a treasured experience
for me
and my family it's a place that made
lincoln
it shaped lincoln and defined the man
that lincoln would become
america is the land of opportunity
as president donald trump declared at
mount rushmore in america you can do
anything
you can be anything and together
we can achieve anything every day
president donald trump is fighting to
protect the promise of american liberty
every day our president's been fighting
to expand the reach of the american
dream
and on every single day without fail
president donald trump has been fighting
for you
so tonight i'd like to introduce you to
a few remarkable americans
who represent that solemn pledge
who embody our president's unbreakable
devotion to ensuring that america
is a land of unlimited opportunity for
all
jack is an eight-year-old from wisconsin
who was struggling academically and
socially in school
but jack's mom sarah who works three
jobs to support her son
applied for wisconsin's school choice
voucher program
we're glad that we were able to get the
school choice voucher to
go to that school with jack he would
have slipped through the cracks in
public schools
and having the option to go to a school
that fits
him has been a real game changer for us
and i know that because of that
opportunity that
he's going to succeed and he's going to
um
achieve that goal of being an apparatus
engineer if that's what he
chooses to stick with laura mclin
is a mother of another inspiring boy
jordan
jordan has duchenne muscular dystrophy a
fatal muscle weakening disorder
jordan was at my side in indiana when as
governor i
signed a law allowing terminally ill
patients to access
experimental drugs not yet approved by
the fda
in 2018 president trump signed the
landmark
federal right to try bill into law
thanks to the president's leadership
critically ill patients have the right
to access life-saving experimental
treatments
we started fighting for right to try
which basically says
if you have a terminal illness and
there's a drug that exists and you don't
qualify for the clinical trial there's
no other way to receive it
this is a unique pathway that allows you
to have access
you made us a promise back in indiana
that you would do whatever
it took to help jordan and we're so
grateful that you joined us on this
journey
and um suck it out until it became law
so that other people could access
treatments
so jordan if president trump was
standing right there what would you say
to him today about right to try
you for being a hero to everybody in the
country
[Music]
judge cheryl allen made history in 2007
when she became the first
african-american woman to be elected to
serve on the pennsylvania superior court
it's because of leaders like judge allen
that our nation has overcome our
greatest challenges in this time
of uh racial division in the country
do you see faith and values and
the strong stand that president trump
has taken for equality of opportunity
as a pathway toward bringing the country
together
as a senior citizen i'll leave it at
that
i know what racism feels like but i also
know that but for
my being in this country i would have
never been able to achieve
[Music]
the things that i have been able to
achieve there are
injustices but the way to deal with
those injustices
is for people to sit down across the
table
and talk and come up with solutions i do
believe that
president trump is committed to that in
2016 i have to confess
that i really did not know um
candidate trump at the time but i have
to say that he really won me over
gino's a truck driver from ohio
who heard politicians for years make
empty promises about defending american
jobs
only to see those promises broken again
and again
but in 2019 when general motors closed
its plant in lordstown ohio
president donald trump refused to stand
by and watch it happen
and as gino observed this president
reached out to general motors
to find a way to bring jobs back to
lordstown
and plans were soon set into motion to
create
wardstown motors president trump says
this is how we fix it
and i thought well that's a simple
solution there's no other president
there's no one that has even tried to do
it president trump's a doer
he appreciates every one of us and i
know he does i've seen it
when he said make america great again
that was his task
that wasn't that wasn't his slogan that
was his task
in every hat you see that says mega on
it that's what your president's doing
for you
thank you mr president for keeping the
promises that you made
and then there's pastor aaron johnson
today he's the executive director of the
tulsa dream center
a non-profit that provides education and
medical services and food to those in
need
aj you've got a great personal story
when you see the way
this president this administration has
been leaning in
to create opportunities investments in
communities around the country to create
jobs
expanding educational choice what what
does that mean to the families that you
serve every day
it means so much to our families i did
grow up in a single parent home and so
we serve over 600 boys and girls right
now on a daily basis
even in covet and so for us to give
these moms to have an opportunity
to take more money on their check on
their paycheck home back to them
to have their children be able to go to
a school that they may not have the
opportunity to otherwise
it means so much to us there's been so
much greater opportunity for individuals
to come together in any walk of life
people have really been able to see such
a positive change
and been filled with hope especially
throughout this time
lydia left hearth and home friends and
family in honduras
to pursue a better life here in america
while raising their four daughters lydia
and her husband
run a small business that creates
security systems but
just months after their business was up
and running our nation was struck by a
global pandemic
that's when president donald trump
stepped in and enacted the largest
financial relief package
in american history her small business
stayed in business
and her american dream kept running
strong what did the paycheck protection
program
mean to your company as
the coronavis struck yeah it was a huge
tremendous help and a big blessing and
so we applied we were accepted
really quickly we're so grateful you
can't believe
how much relief we have we wanted to
continue serving our clients we want to
continue
growing our economy right we want to all
continue to move forward
so we were able to make it
[Music]
because of the support of family and
friends
the government
i tell my children you know they are
born here in the u.s and i tell them
you are so blessed to live in america
here at abraham lincoln's boyhood home a
young man would grow up to become the
first
republican president of the united
states and today
another republican president is fighting
to preserve that same
noble legacy of freedom and president
donald trump
will make certain that the torch of
american opportunity illuminates every
city
every town and every community in this
blessed land
hi i'm ryan hulitz i'm a police officer
from new mexico
in 2017 i had an encounter that changed
my life forever
i had just started my shift and
responded to a call for service at a gas
station
when i arrived i saw a man and a woman
sitting on a grassy slope
i recognized the telltale signs a needle
a spoon
i knew immediately that they were
preparing to inject themselves with
heroin
sadly this is a common sight for me i
encounter the ravages of addiction
every day but nothing
could prepare me for what i discovered
as i approached them
the woman was very pregnant in my shock
i asked her if she knew that she was
harming her baby by doing drugs
she crumbled and burst into tears
two worlds collided as i knelt down
beside her
a police officer and a homeless drug
addict
brought together by forces outside of
our control
as we talked our humanity distinct
from our stations in life was made
abundantly clear
her name was crystal and in the midst of
her suffering
she confided that she loved her unborn
baby
she wanted the best for her child in
that moment
i saw her the way that all of you who
know and love an addict see them
as fathers mothers brothers sisters
children cousins and friends as
human beings full of value and dignity
but robbed of their potential by this
disease
when crystal said that she was looking
for a family to adopt her baby
god showed me exactly what i had to do
without hesitation
i told her that my family would welcome
her baby through adoption
today our beautiful daughter hope is a
thriving two-year-old
crystal is fast approaching three years
of recovery
she is a dear friend and a constant
inspiration
to me and others i hold a special place
in my heart for those facing opioid
addiction
and that's why i'm enormously grateful
to the president
for his leadership in fighting this
deadly enemy
through his efforts we're turning the
tide on the crisis of addiction
president trump declared the opioid
crisis to be a public health emergency
and then secured six billion dollars in
new federal funding to help americans
fight
opioid abuse he invested an additional
100 million dollars to stop the opioid
crisis
in rural america and in a move that
strikes at the root
of the problem he implemented a safer
prescribing plan
aimed at reducing opioid prescriptions
by over a
third within three years this is an
effort that stops addiction before it
ever gains a hold in someone's life
and it's having an impact drug overdose
deaths
decreased in 2018 for the first time in
30 years many of the state's hardest hit
by the opioid crisis
are seeing the largest drop in deaths
we're seeing that doctors are writing
fewer prescriptions
for opioid pain drugs these are
significant improvements
that have a meaningful impact
i think we are fortunate america to have
a president
who cares deeply for the downtrodden and
who works tirelessly
to find solutions a president who
doesn't just
talk about problems but stops and helps
president trump is the leader we've
needed the last four years
and he is the leader we need for the
next four you see
donald trump is the right president at
the right time
let's make sure he's reelected on
november
3rd i pray god's blessings on you and
your family
and may god bless america
good evening my name is jeanette nunez
and i'm proud to serve as lieutenant
governor of the great state of florida
tonight i'm honored to share my story of
faith
family and american freedom
as the daughter of cuban immigrants my
story began
in 1959 before i was born
when my parents dreams of a prosperous
life
became a nightmare chaos sparred quickly
when fidel castro took control of cuba
the government confiscated private
property stealing people's homes
farms and businesses from my parents
the difficult decision to flee communist
cuba
came when the castro regime abolished
religious freedom
fellow americans the fabric of our
nation is in peril
daily the radical left systematically
chisels away
at the freedoms we cherish they peddle
dangerous ideologies
cower to global progressives and
normalize socialism
to dismantle our constitution let me
assure you
socialism doesn't offer opportunity
socialism deprives it is a falsehood
that feigns promises for its masses and
consistently yields
only misery president ronald reagan
warned
if we lose freedom here there's no place
to escape to
truer words have never been spoken
americans have a choice we can go down a
dark road
of chaos and government control or we
can choose the path of freedom
and opportunity that was paved by those
who sacrificed everything to preserve
the american dream
for future generations i have faith
that americans will choose the right
path in 2016
our country yearned for a leader who
would work tirelessly
to jump start our economy and fight for
hard-working americans
since day one president donald trump
has put america first his pro-growth
pro-jobs agenda has ushered in
historically low unemployment
record job creation higher wages
and rising home ownership the president
is fighting
to rescue american jobs and industries
for places like ohio
pennsylvania and puerto rico
jobs that were needlessly shipped
overseas he's defended our religious
freedom
stood with democratic allies like
colombia and shown unwavering resolve
while confronting tyrants in countries
like venezuela
cuba china and nicaragua
let us join our president in his vow
that america will never be a socialist
country
supporting our president requires action
join me tonight and text vote
to eight eight zero two two
we must continue to support our
commander-in-chief
who has a bold agenda that safeguards
the rights
and freedoms protected under our
constitution
today more than ever that means
supporting our men and women in law
enforcement
and our heroes in uniform it means
fighting to provide the best quality
education
by empowering parents and preserving
school choice
and it means rejecting the socialist
takeover
of our nation that will destroy the
innovation
economic vitality and freedoms we hold
so dear
as a daughter of immigrants a wife
a mother of three and the first latina
lieutenant governor in the history of
the state of florida
it is my distinct privilege to share my
story
which is really your story and the story
of a nation
that has opened its doors lifted its
people
and yielded success in a way only the
united states of america can
together let's ensure four more years
for president donald j trump so that he
can continue protecting our republic
and so one day our children can proudly
tell the story
of what our generation did to defend the
values
of faith family
and freedom thank you may god bless
each one of you and may god bless the
united states of america
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
[Music]
acting secretary wolf i present to you
five candidates for naturalization
representing five
countries on behalf of everyone here
today i'd like to express my gratitude
to you mr president for hosting this
naturalization ceremony
here at the white house to our
candidates it is my honor to administer
the oath of allegiance and welcome you
as our fellow citizens
candidates for naturalization please
raise your right hand
and repeat after me i hereby declare
an oath that i absolutely and entirely
renounce and observe
all
of whom or which
the constitution and laws the
constitutional laws
of the united states of america of the
united states of america
against all enemies against all enemies
foreign
on behalf of the united states on behalf
of the united states when required by
law
[Music]
that i will perform work
and that i take this obligation freely
that i take this obligation
freely without any mental reservation
without
any mental relationship or purpose of
division
so help me god congratulations you're
now
citizens of the
[Applause]
on behalf of the department of homeland
security it is my honor to call you my
fellow americans
mr president i want to again commend you
for your dedication to the rule of law
and for restoring integrity to our
immigration system thank you for hosting
such a patriotic
celebration here at the white house
today
congratulations that's fantastic it's
really great
thank you and i want to thank
acting secretary wolf doing a phenomenal
job in so many ways
today america rejoices as we welcome
five absolutely incredible new members
into our great
american family you are now fellow
citizens of the greatest nation
on the face of god's earth
congratulations
great going you followed the rules you
obeyed the laws
you learned your history embraced our
values and proved yourselves to be
men and women of the highest integrity
it's not so easy you went through a lot
and we appreciate you being here with us
today
you've earned the most prized treasured
cherished
and priceless possession anywhere in the
world it's called
american citizenship there is no higher
honor and no greater privilege
and it's an honor for me to be your
president
thank you very much at this time i'd
like to recognize the five new citizens
who join us
today robert martin
ramirez al-khasar is from bolivia
and has been a lawful permanent resident
of the united states since
2013. robert hi robert
he and his wife are raising three
beautiful children
in 2017 robert achieved the dream of
starting his own business
a construction company that now employs
five workers
robert says i love this country i want
to respect the law
america has helped me so much in life
robert thank you very much for your
devotion thank you
for the pure trinities to the united
states well thank you and good luck with
that company
soon you'll have hundreds of employees i
think right
that could happen could happen it will
rima gideon is from lebanon and is the
proud mother of three
children rima speaks english arabic and
french and earned a degree in
psychology in other words she can figure
me out
she now works as a daycare teacher in
virginia
riemer says i feel blessed to be a loyal
citizen of the greatest country in the
world
a country that has given me the
opportunity of a lifetime to realize my
potential and my dreams
rhema congratulations it's really great
thank you
thank you so much that's very good thank
you very much
i appreciate it
sandari narayan
is a phenomenal
success born in india came to the united
states
13 years ago suda is a talented software
developer and
she and her husband are raising two
beautiful
wonderful children the apples of your
life
right well thank you very much and
congratulations
fantastic job thank you name it
abdulzyme awolo side
is from sudan and that's a beautiful
name and has been a lawful permanent
resident since 2012.
she is the married mother of three
beautiful children earned a master's
degree and phd
in animal nutrition from the university
of wyoming great place great state
and she is a trained veterinarian she's
also worked as a substitute teacher
for the alexandria public school since
2004. that's fantastic
well diamond thank you very much and
congratulations it's
my honor to be with you thank you thank
you very much
salah abdul samad has been looking
forward to this day since he arrived
in the united states from ghana in 2015.
sally speaks five languages and works
the medical field sally says that the
american citizenship
means everything to me in my life it
cannot be measured or quantified
i have the chance to work hard and
succeed in life
to know that i am in the safe country
like america
that really is something because i know
they have my back
sally thank you very much
congratulations fantastic job
congratulations to everybody with the
rights and freedoms each of you now
enjoys the citizens there is no dream
beyond
your wildest reach because americans can
do anything
today you have also accepted the
profound duties and responsibilities
that come with
american citizenship by swearing the
oath of allegiance
each of you has entered a sacred and
unbreakable covenant
with our nation you have pledged your
undying loyalty to the american people
the american constitution
and the american way of life the history
and heritage of the united states are
now yours to preserve and pass down
to the next generation our culture our
traditions and our values are now yours
to uphold and live by
the right so dear to every american
granted by
us and granted by god
and enshrined in our glorious bill of
rights
are now yours to support protect
and defend as citizens you're now
stewards of this
magnificent nation a family comprised of
every race color religion and creed
united by the bonds of love we are one
people sharing one home saluting one
great american flag
congratulations again to all of you may
god bless you and may god bless
our great country america
[Music]
good evening america when i stood on
this convention stage four years ago
no one fully understood the historic
change that was about to take place
we could all feel it something was
happening
a movement was forming just below the
surface the forgotten man and woman
voiceless in washington dc were
preparing to rise up
our movement followed the pattern of so
many that came before us
first we were ignored then we were
laughed at
then they fought us and then together
we won from that moment forward america
came first
america started winning again america
became respected again
but with every movement there's a
counter movement in the view of the
radical democrats
america is the source of the world's
problems
as a result they believe the only path
forward is to raise history
and forget the past they want to destroy
the monuments of our forefathers
they want to disrespect our flag burn
the stars and stripes that represent
patriotism
and the american dream they want to
disrespect our national anthem by taking
a knee
while our armed forces lay down their
lives every day
to protect our freedom they do not want
the pledge of allegiance in our schools
many of them don't want one nation under
god
the democrats want to defund and
disrespect our law enforcement
the democrats want a miracle where your
thoughts and opinions are censored when
they do not align with their own
president reagan said freedom is never
more than one generation away from
extinction
it must be fought for and it must be
protected this
is the fight that we are in right now
and it is a fight
that only my father can win my father
man not because he needed the job
but because he knew hard-working people
across this great country were being
left behind
the media mocked these patriots in the
flyover states in which they lived
they ignored the trump flags they
ignored the millions of mega banners and
barns painted in red
white and blue the silent majority had
no one fighting for them in either party
their so-called leaders were bowing to
china bribing iran
and spending more time worrying about
how they'd be received by the elites in
paris
than how americans would provide for
their families in pittsburgh
our family lost friends but it only
pushed us to fight harder
my father pledged to every american in
every city
state and town that he was going to make
america great again
and so began the great american comeback
almost immediately taxes were slashed
regulations were cut
and the economy soared to new heights
heights never seen before
wages went through the roof unemployment
reached the historic lows especially for
black americans
hispanic americans and women trade deals
were ripped up and renegotiated
lights were turned back on in abandoned
factories across our country
trillions of dollars were repatriated
back to the united states
which had been sitting in foreign lands
for far too long
once again america became the envy of
the world
and with that renewed strength came
leverage the president demanded that our
allies pay their fair share for the
defense of the western world
my father rebuilt the mighty american
military adding new jets aircraft
carriers
he increased wages for incredible men
and women in uniform
he expanded our military defense budget
to 721 billion
dollars per year america was no longer
weak in the eye of the enemy
the moment president trump ordered
special forces kill some of the
deadliest terrorists on the planet
the day the mighty moab was dropped on
the surging camps
is the day america took a stance and
never be defeated
by the enemy al-baghdadi soleimani
dead over and over issue after issue
the economy the wall the military trade
deals tax cuts
supreme court justices va hospitals
prescription drugs school choice right
to try
moving the embassy to jerusalem peace in
the middle east
never ending wars were finally ended
promises
made and promises for the first time
were kept
most politicians spend their entire
careers in washington dc and get
absolutely nothing accomplished
for example joe biden joe biden is a
politician who has been in government
for 47
years he's a career politician who's
never signed the front of a check
and does not know the slightest thing
about the american worker
or the american business the engine
which fuels the greatest economy the
world has ever known
the same politician who has been a total
pushover for communist china
and someone who would be a giant relief
for terrorists who now spend years
running
hiding and being taken out by the most
talented
military known to man
joe biden has pledged to raise your
taxes by 4 trillion dollars
82 percent of americans will see their
taxes go up significantly
biden has pledged to stop border wall
construction and give amnesty
and health care to all illegal
immigrants
fighting his pledge to defund the police
and take away your cherished
second amendment my father on the other
hand delivered the largest tax cuts in
american history
knows if you do not have a border you do
not have a country
and will always support law enforcement
and your right to keep
and bear arms every day my father fights
for the american people
the forgotten man and woman of this
country
the ones who embody the american spirit
which is unlike anything else in the
world
it built a new york city skyline it
built the hoover dam
and soon under my father's leadership it
will send
americans to mars the american spirit
can be felt in the majesty of the grand
canyon
the shadows of mount rushmore and the
stillness
of the era gettysburg it can be seen in
the wide-eyed wonder of
every american child as they take their
first breath
in the greatest country the world has
ever known
it defeated fascism it defeated
communism
and in 68 days it will defeat the empty
oppressive and radical views of the
extreme left
ronald reagan's quote ends with this
simple warning
one day we could spend our sunset years
telling our children
what it was once like in the united
states where men
and women were free under president
trump freedom will never be a thing of
the past
that's what a vote for donald trump
represents it's a vote for the american
spirit
the american dream and for the american
flag
to the law enforcement officer who's
being attacked
betrayed and whose job they are trying
to make extinct
my father will fight for you
to all houses of worship and to all
people of faith stripped of our
religious freedoms
and religious liberties my father will
fight for you
to the voiceless shamed censored
and cancelled my father will fight for
you
to our farmers who worked on to dust to
keep our plates full
my father will fight for you to every
single mother and father
to our veterans our coal miners and to
the american
worker my father will fight for you
and to every proud american who bleeds
red
white and blue my father will continue
to fight for you
in closing i'd like to speak directly to
my father i miss working alongside you
every
single day but i'm damn proud to be on
the front lines of this fight
i'm proud of what you're doing for this
country i'm proud to show my children
what their grandfather is fighting for
i'm proud to watch you give them hell
never stop continue to be unapologetic
keep fighting for what is right you are
making america strong again
you are making america safe again you
are making america proud again
and yes together with a forgotten man
and woman who are finally forgotten no
more
you are making america great again
dad let's make uncle robert very proud
this week
let's go get another four years i love
you
very much god bless you and god bless
the united states of america
[Music]
we're going to build a future of safety
and opportunity for americans
of every race color religion and freedom
our president has created such a surplus
that when this pandemic hit he was able
to refund americans without indebting us
we're all better off when former inmates
can receive
and re-enter society as law-abiding
productive
citizens and now have a chance at more
opportunities than they've ever had
before
to be incarcerated for 16 and a half
years
for hearsay i get emotional
about it it's a feeling that i can't
describe
when people say we're oppressed here in
the united states
how right now this country for me is the
last beacon
of hope and opportunity if
america falls the entire war falls
trump's pledge
to the american workers definitely means
a lot to me because
i wouldn't be where i'm at today i truly
believe that my kids are going to look
up to me one day
it's just tremendous what i could do i
guess
the forgotten men and women will never
be forgotten again you know in biden's
america
there aren't opportunity zones here you
have an administration
that actually looks at how can
government and private enterprise work
together
as we fight to deliver a better future
for all women
and for all americans we remember the
wonderful victory
one century ago and in the coming
november the ladies appeared at the
polls
on election day by the hundreds of
thousands they had won their right to
vote
before the china virus set in it struck
our nation
women had gained 4.3 million jobs
a record the women's unemployment rate
had plummeted
to the lowest level in more than 65
years
and last year over 70 percent of the new
jobs went to women and i will say we're
coming back very strongly we have the
most opportunity that's the american
story
that we have hope that even though we're
in dark days now
that the days ahead
hold greater possibilities
because of the opportunities that we've
been given in our country
and we will make america great again
good evening my name is daniel cameron
i'm 34 years old and the first
african-american attorney general in
kentucky history
it is an honor to be with you as a proud
republican
and supporter of donald j trump i was
raised in kentucky
just a few miles from abraham lincoln's
birthplace
our first republican president believed
in compassion
self-reliance freedom equality
and justice sadly
there are some who don't believe in this
wisdom or in the better angels
of our shared american history as they
tear down the statues of people like
ulysses s
grant frederick douglass and even mr
lincoln himself
lincoln said any nation that does not
honor its heroes
will not long endure and for republicans
our heroes are those who propelled an
imperfect nation
ever forward always striving to make
life better
for everyone even as anarchists
mindlessly tear up american cities while
attacking police
and innocent bystanders we republicans
do recognize those who work in good
faith
towards peace justice and equality
in fact it was general dwight eisenhower
a future republican president
who said democracy is a system that
recognizes
the equality of humans before the law
whether you are the family of brianna
taylor or david dorn
these are the ideals that will heal our
nation's wounds
republicans will never turn a blind eye
to unjust acts
but neither will we accept an all-out
assault
on western civilization
my values were shaped by my faith
and by my parents i worked at their
small coffee shop
meeting people from all walks of life
and i realized something
no matter who we are everyone needs a
cup of coffee
that lesson stuck with me because
despite our differences
we all want the same things for our
children to have more opportunities
than we did to feel the dignity of work
and to believe that if you play by the
rules you can make a good life
for yourself and your family so the
question is
will we choose the path that gives us
the best chance
to meet those universal desires or will
we go back
to a time when people were treated like
political commodities
who can't be trusted to think for
themselves
i think often about my ancestors who
struggled for freedom
and as i think of those giants and their
broad shoulders
i also think about joe biden who says
if you aren't voting for me you ain't
black
who argued that republicans would put us
back in chains
who says there is no diversity of
thought in the black community
mr vice president look at me i am black
we are not all the same sir i am not in
chains
my mind is my own and you can't tell me
how to vote because of the color of my
skin
joe biden is a backwards thinker in a
world that is
craving forward-looking leadership
there's no wisdom in his record or plan
just a trail of discredited ideas and
offensive statements
joe biden would destroy jobs raise our
taxes
and throw away the lives of countless
unborn children and he is captive to the
radical left
a movement committed to cancel culture
and the destruction of public discourse
they believe your skin color must
dictate your politics
and if you fail to conform while
exercising your god-given right to speak
and think freely
they will cut you down
the politics of identity cancellation
and mob rule
are not acceptable to me republicans
trust
you to think for yourself and to pursue
your american dream however you see
fit mr lincoln said the dogmas of the
quiet past
are inadequate to the stormy present the
occasion
is piled high with difficulty and we
must rise to the occasion
i believe donald trump can meet
lincoln's mandate
even as joe biden remains trapped by his
own failed record
and by the radicals who dominate his
party
let's be honest no one is excited about
joe biden
and so i asked you to judge the record
on criminal justice reform
joe biden couldn't do it but president
trump
did on the economy joe biden
couldn't do it but president trump did
build an economy
that worked for everyone especially
minorities
and he will do it again and on
immigration joe biden promises more to
illegal immigrants
than he does to you but president trump
believes
his highest duty is to the american
worker
the choice is clear let me close with
something my mom told me
this country's many faces comprise a
family
not separate parts to be divided against
each other
and like any family we care for one
another we grieve together we share our
burdens and our struggles
and we celebrate our successes and
though we fuss and fight
we are not enemies we are americans
united by a collective faith in our
constitution
and laws and the fundamental fairness
they represent
we are defenders of life and of
individual liberty
and we carry the mantle of eisenhower
and of reagan
to be a force for good in this world and
one that must
always be reckoned with that's my
republican party
the party of lincoln that believes
america is an
indispensable nation an evergreen tree
standing tall in a turbulent world
and that's why i am voting for donald
trump
for president thank you and god bless
[Music]
hi i'm mike pompeo i'm speaking to you
from beautiful jerusalem
looking out over the old city i have a
big job
as susan's husband and nick's dad susan
and nick
are more safe and their freedom's more
secure because president trump has put
his america first vision
into action it may not have made him
popular in every foreign capital
but it's worked president trump
understands
what my great fellow kansas and
president eisenhower said
for all that we cherish and justly
desire for ourselves
or for our children the securing of
peace is the first
requisite indeed the primary
constitutional function
of the national government is ensuring
that your family and mine
are safe and enjoy the freedom to live
to work
to learn and to worship as they choose
delivering on this duty to keep us safe
and our freedoms intact
this president has led bold initiatives
in nearly every corner of the world
in china he's pulled back the curtain on
the predatory aggression
of the chinese communist party the
president has held china accountable for
covering up the china virus
and allowing it to spread death and
economic destruction in america
and around the world and he will not
rest until justice is done
he has ensured that the chinese
communist party spies posing as
diplomats in america
or jailed or sent back to china and he
has ended the ridiculously unfair trade
arrangement
with china that punched a hole in our
economy
those jobs those jobs are coming back
home
in north korea the president lowered the
temperature
and against all odds got the north
korean leadership to the table
no nuclear tests no long-range missile
tests
and americans held captive in north
korea came home to their families
as did the precious remains of scores of
heroes who fought
in korea today today because of
president trump nato is stronger
ukraine has defensive weapon systems and
america left a harmful treaty so our
nation can now build missiles to deter
russian aggression
and in the middle east when iran
threatened the president approved a
strike that killed the iranian terrorist
qasim suleimani this is the man most
responsible for the murder and maiming
of hundreds of american soldiers
and thousands of christians across the
middle east
and you'll recall too that when the
president took office
radical islamic terrorists had beheaded
americans and isis controlled a
territory in the size of the size of
great britain
today today because of the president's
determination and leadership
the isis caliphate is wiped out it's
gone it's evil leader
abu bakr al-baghdadi is dead and our
brave soldiers
they're on their way home the president
exited
the u.s from the disastrous nuclear deal
with iran
and squeeze the ayatollah hezbollah and
hamas
the president too moved the u.s embassy
to this very city of god jerusalem
the rightful capital of the jewish
homeland
and just two weeks ago the president
brokered a historic peace deal
between israel and the united arab
emirates this is the deal that our
grandchildren will read about in their
history books
you know as a soldier i saw firsthand
people
desperate to flee to freedom the way
each of us
can best ensure our freedoms is by
electing leaders who don't just talk
but who deliver an american hostage
imprisoned in turkey for two years
pastor andrew brunson
said upon his release that he survived
his ordeal with these words of scripture
be faithful endure and finish well
if we stay the course we will
may god richly bless you and may god
bless our great nation
the united states of america
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my great honor to present
first lady melania trump first lady
melania trump
first lady melania trump officially
kicking off her best initiative
she is courageous she's taking on a
tough topic focused on the well-being of
children
social media use and opioid abuse let's
join together
in your committing to help children
dream big
think big and do all they can to be best
in everything
this is her showcasing what she brings
to the position of first lady
she is smart independent and i think
people have underestimated her big time
the first lady was amazing she was
gracious
empathetic and showed true compassion
first lady melania trump stepping out
onto the world stage
the bee based campaign is now going
international
she has the advantage of speaking
several languages
she can be a diplomat for our country
the sun was shiny she was greeted by
children
this of course is her continuing to work
on for the best campaign
by shining a spotlight on successful
programs that teach
children tools and skills he represents
our country
enormous warmth and elegance and grace
throughout history
women have made lasting impacts on
society
and these women represent the strength
of the female spirit
as first lady of the united states i'm
proud of what this country continues to
do for women
we as women must continue using our
great
tool of empowerment our voices
it was a very important moment for
melanie trump this was a really
prominent week for her the iconic
white house rose garden has been
renovated for the first time in
60 years when the history books are
written there should be a special
chapter reserved
for our first lady she is an incredible
first lady
an amazing mother an incredible
woman first lady melania trump
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
first lady of the united states
mrs melania trump
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
good evening it seems
like just yesterday that we were at our
first convention
where my husband accepted the republican
nomination
and then became our 45th president
of the united states yet the energy
and enthusiasm for who should lead this
nation
it is real today as it was four years
ago
i know i speak for my husband and the
entire family
when i say we have not forgotten the
incredible people
who are willing to take a chance on the
businessmen
who had never worked in politics
we know it was you who elected him to be
commander-in-chief and we know it is you
who will carry us through again
we were humbled by the incredible
support then
and we are still grateful today
i want to acknowledge the fact that
since march
our lives have changed drastically
the invisible enemy covet 19
swept across our beautiful country and
impacted
all of us my deepest sympathy
goes out to everyone who has lost
a loved one and my prayers are with
those
who are ill or suffering
i know many people are anxious
and some feel helpless i want you to
know
you're not alone my husband's
administration
will not stop fighting until there is an
effective treatment
or vaccine available to everyone
donald will not rest until he has done
all he can to take care of everyone
impacted by this terrible pandemic
i want to extend my gratitude to all of
the health care professionals
frontline workers and teachers who
stepped up
in these difficult times despite the
risk to yourselves
and your own families you put our
country first
and my husband and i are grateful
i have been moved by the way americans
have come together
in such an unfamiliar and often
frightening situation
it is in times like this that we will
look back
and tell our grandchildren that through
kindness and compassion
strength and determination we were able
to restore
the promise of our future
businesses stepped up and volunteers
stepped in
people were eager to share ideas
resources
and support of all kinds with neighbors
and strangers alike
it has been inspiring to see what the
people of our great nation will do for
one another
especially when we are at our most
fragile
speaking of strength and determination
we recently celebrated
the 100 year anniversary of the passage
of the 19th amendment
yesterday on the north lawn of the white
house
we unveiled an exhibit dedicated to
women's suffrage
the exhibit called on children from
across the country
to send art honoring the meaning of this
important time in women's history
when i was judging the entries i
reflected on the impact
of women's voices in our nation's story
and how proud i will be to cast my vote
again
for donald this november
we must make sure that women are heard
and that american dream continues to
thrive
growing up as a young child in slovenia
which was under communist rule at the
time
i always heard about an amazing place
called america
a land that stood for freedom and
opportunity
as i grew older it became my goal to
move to the united states
and follow my dream of working in the
fashion industry
my parents worked very hard to ensure
our family
could not only live and prosper in
america
but also contribute to a nation that
allows for people
to arrive with a dream and make it
reality
i want to take the moment to thank my
mother
and father for all they have done for
our family
it is because of you that i'm standing
here today
i arrived in the united states when i
was 26 years old
living and working in the land of
opportunity
was a dream come true but i wanted more
i wanted to be a citizen after 10 years
of paperwork and patience i studied for
the test
in 2006 and became an american citizen
it is still one of the proudest moments
in my life
because with hard work and determination
i was able to achieve my own american
dream
as an immigrant and a very independent
woman
i understand what a privilege it is to
live here
and to enjoy the freedoms and
opportunities
that we have as first lady
i have been fortunate to see the
american dream
come true over and over again
i have met many inspiring women
children parents and families
who have overcome life-changing issues
that include addiction homelessness
family members who are ill or have
passed away
abuse of all kinds and many other
challenges
that would make most people give up the
past three and a half years
have been unforgettable there are no
words to describe
how honored humbled and fortunate i am
to serve our nation as your first lady
after many of the experiences i've had
i don't know if i can fully explain how
many people
i take home with me in my heart each day
from brave soldiers who give up so much
so that we can be free to children of
all
circumstances who i have met around the
world
thank you for inspiring me
it is my greatest honor to serve you
when i speak to members of the military
despite sacrificing time with their
families
experience the fear of war or suffering
loss
they have no regrets about serving our
country
the same goes for their families and the
families
of first responders who often watch
their loved ones
walk out the door not sure if
or when they will come home
when i speak to families who have lost
someone the pain mixed with pride
i hear in their voices is something i
think about
often so thank you to all who serve
our country in the military and as first
responders
and thank you to the families who wait
for them
you are heroes in your own right
i have also been moved by the many
children and families i've spent time
with
at hospitals schools and other locations
around the world children who are
dealing with pain or illness
that would break even the strongest
adult
parents who are grateful to wake up
every day
and see that their child is still alive
these families
are a testament to what faith and
medicine
strength and science can do
on my first international trip as first
lady
my husband and i visited places of great
significance
to the three major religions islam
christianity and judaism
one special memory from that trip is of
a young
boy i had privilege of visiting while at
bambino jizu hospital in rome
italy while there i read a little boy a
story
and learned that he and his family had
been waiting for a heart
for a very long time and he had a green
prognosis
his situation brought my staff and me to
tears
and we spoke of a little else as we flew
to belgium
for the next part of our trip
upon landing just a few hours later we
learned
that a heart had been donated and would
be going
to the little one i think about him
often
along with so many amazing and strong
young patients
across our own country
more profound and sadly unavoidable
examples
of our country's strength and character
have occurred in the communities that
have been impacted by natural disasters
hurricanes tornadoes and flooding may
show the ugly side of mother nature
but in the aftermath they can show us a
beautiful side of humanity
my husband and i have visited many
places
that have been affected by natural
disaster
and we are deeply moved by the strength
of the people
who have lost everything and the
kindness
of neighbors and communities
the common thread in all of these
challenging situations
is the unwavering resolve to help one
another
i recognize the stories i just told
about people who survive extraordinary
circumstances
but donald and i are also inspired by
the millions
of americans who wake up each day with a
simple yet courageous goal
of providing for their families and
keeping them safe
you are the backbone of this country
you are the people who continue to make
the united states of america what it is
and who have the incredible
responsibility
of preparing our future generations to
leave
everything even better than they found
it
just as you are fighting for your
families
my husband our family and the people in
this administration
are here fighting for you no matter the
amount of negative or false media
headlines
or attacks from the other side donald
trump
has not and will not lose focus on you
he loves this country and he knows how
to get things done
as you have learned over the past five
years he is not a traditional politician
he doesn't just speak words he demands
action
and he gets results the future of our
country
has always been very important to him
and it is something
that i have always admired
in fact it is to help ensure a better
future
for our next generation that i launched
be best
my initiative to help children achieve
their fullest potential be best has one
simple goal
teaching youth about the importance of
their well-being
both mentally and physically
this also includes understanding online
safety
and the danger of opioid and drug abuse
to be best my office and i have been
able to highlight people
programs and organizations that are
doing
extraordinary things in our country
and around the world i continue i
continue to believe
that by shining a light on these
positive examples
others across the country and globe will
become inspired
to do a part for our next generation
helping children is not a political goal
it is our moral imperative
when i think back to a defining moment
of be best
my mind goes to a trip i took to africa
on that vast and beautiful continent i
was able to visit
the countries of ghana malawi kenya
and egypt one of those visits
in particular had a profound impact on
me
ghana on the coast of west africa
was the first stop on my trip and i
experienced
firsthand its warm people and their
traditions
while there i visited the cape coast
castle
and learned more about the beginning of
a cruel and often deadly
journey in the era of the slave trade
i was horrified when i listened to the
guide
tell me so many inhumane stories and i
gained new perspectives
this time in our history we must never
forget
so that we can ensure that it never
happens again
like all of you i have reflected on the
racial
unrest in our country
it is a harsh reality that we are not
proud
of parts of our history
i encourage people to focus on our
future
while still learning from our past
we must remember that today we are all
one community comprised of many races
religions and ethnicities our diverse
and storied history is what makes our
country strong
and yet we still have so much to learn
from one another with that in mind
i like to call on the citizens of this
country
to take a moment pause and look at
things from
all perspectives i urge people
to come together in a civil manner so we
can work
and live up to our standard american
ideals
i also ask people to stop the violence
and looting being done in the name of
justice
and never make assumptions based on the
color of a person's skin
instead of tearing things down tearing
things down
let's reflect on our mistakes
be proud of our evolution and look
to our way forward
every day let us remember that we are
one nation
under god and we need to cherish one
another
my husband's administration has worked
to try and affect change when it comes
to issues around
race and religion in this country
he is the first president to address a
special
sensation of the united nations general
assembly
to call upon countries across the world
to end religious prosecution
and honor the right of every person
to worship as they choose
he has made substantial investments in
our historically black colleges
and universities this president
also continues to fight for school
choice
giving parents more options to help
their children flourish
my husband knows how to make a real
change
from the day that i met him he has only
wanted to make this country the best
it can be for many years
i watched him grow concerned and
frustrated
and i'm so proud to see the many things
he has done
in such a short time america
is in his heart so while at times we
only see the worst of people and
politics on the evening news
let's remember how we come together
in the most difficult times
and while the debate rage on about
issues of race
let's focus on the strides we have made
and work together
for a better tomorrow for everyone
our administration has also devoted
historic resources
and produced life-saving results by
raising awareness
around opioid addiction and drug abuse
especially for children when so often
the headlines are filled with gossip
i want to take this moment to encourage
the media
to focus even more on the nation's drug
crisis
this disease is one that affects
everybody
it pays no attention to race age
or socio-economic status
addiction has touched every part of our
society
in some way and now more than ever
we have programs and medicine to combat
it
we just need to talk about it openly and
you
the media have the platforms to make
that happen
to the media industry and as a country i
ask that we all commit to helping in our
fights against drug addiction
by talking about it even more
especially as we battle the kovit
pandemic
we need to remember that suede suicides
are on the rise as people who are
struggling with
loneliness and addiction feel they have
nowhere to turn
parents please talk to your children
teachers
and caregivers pay attention to signs of
addiction
lawmakers pass legislation that allows
those who ask for help
to do so safely and without fear
and to provide resources for
organizations
that help people impacted by addiction
when the stigma is removed people will
no longer be ashamed
to ask for help and lives will be saved
and if if you're struggling with
addiction there is no shame
in your illness please seek help you are
worth it
in my next four years as first lady i
will continue to build upon the best and
work with individual states
to pass legislation to take care of our
most vulnerable
i plan to continue the work i have
started with children in foster care
as well as minority communities and
tribal
nations i want to ensure children
are being protected and communities have
the resources
needed to combat drug addiction and
child
neglect or abuse like my husband
and the administration i will continue
to encourage
education that supports a child's
individual needs
it is vital that children are given the
building blocks
to succeed i also look forward to
continue my work to restore the people's
house
which is a lasting symbol of pride for
our nation
i believe this iconic home needs to be
cared for
and preserved so it can be enjoyed by
the people
of this country and visitor from around
the world
for years to come i'm passionate about
this beautiful
house the grounds and all they represent
and now i have a special message for the
mothers of this country
this modern world is moving so fast
and our children face challenges that
seem
to change every few months just like me
i know many of you watch how me and
manipulative
social media can be and just like me i'm
sure
many of you are looking for answers how
to
talk to your children about the downside
of technology
and their relationships with their peers
like every parent in this country i feel
there are so many lessons to teach our
son
and responsibilities as his mother but
there are
just not enough hours in the day to do
it all
i remind myself that i'm more fortunate
than most
and still have days that i look for
wisdom and strength
to the very best i can for heal
to mothers and parents everywhere your
warriors
in my husband you have a president who
will not stop
fighting for you and your families i see
how hard he works each day and night
and despite the unprecedented attacks
from the media and opposition
he will not give up in fact if you tell
him he cannot be done
he just works harder
donnas
donald is a husband who supports me in
all that i do
he has built an administration with an
unprecedented number of women
in leadership roles and has fostered an
environment
where the american people are always the
priority
he welcomes different points of view and
encourage thinking
outside of the box i know i speak for my
husband and the family
when i say we are so grateful that you
have trusted him to be your president
and we will be honored to serve this
incredible country
for four more years
as you have heard this evening i don't
want to use this precious time
attacking the other side because as we
saw last week
that kind of talk only serves to divide
the country further i'm here because we
need my husband to be our president
and commander-in-chief for four more
years he is what
is best for our country we all know
donald trump makes
no secrets about how he feels about
things
total honesty is what we as citizens
deserve
from our president whether you like it
or not
you always know what he's thinking
and that is because he is an authentic
person
who loves this country and its people
and wants to continue
to make it better donald wants to keep
your family safe
he wants to help your family succeed
he wants nothing more than for this
country to prosper
and he doesn't waste time playing
politics
almost four years ago we went into
election day completely underestimated
despite what is being said again this
year i know just as you do
that americans will go to the polls and
roll
on the behalf of their families our
economy
our national security and our children's
future
to vote for those ideals is not a
partisan vote
it is a common sense vote because
those are goals and hopes that we all
believe in
i believe that we need my husband's
leadership now more than ever
in order to bring us back once again to
the greatest economy
and the strongest country ever known
god bless you all your families and god
bless the united states of america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
more
[Music]
how are you doing
okay
uh
i love that guys
no she gets it by the way
more thirsty
um
here
no i don't know
okay
we don't have a problem
okay let me give you my phone number
you